the Aquila isn't the biggest drone in
the sky it didn't fly for the longest
time or the highest altitude but its
maiden voyage is still a milestone for
internet access and for Facebook
the drone is part of Facebook's plan to
connect remote parts of the world to the
web it isn't the only tech giant with
those aspirations google has its own
flying drones and high flying altitude
balloons both companies are serving
themselves of course but they're also
helping the world communicate and that's
why this short flight over Arizona is so
important the plan is to power the
drones with the Sun so they can stay
aloft for months at a time
Facebook is fashioning all sorts of
other contraptions that can push towards
its goal including new wireless antennas
lasers and satellites but Aquila itself
is still unfinished lacking the solar
panels batteries and other equipment she
will eventually carry into the skies
once finished though Facebook actually
doesn't want to operate these drones the
plan is to give the designs away so that
local governments or Internet service
providers can fly them delivering
signals to rural areas down on earth and
getting buy-in from these third parties
may be the hardest part of Facebook's
grand plan they have to complete the
design first which is years away but the
project is certainly off the ground